in accra es notfallambulanz hat dr bena
yeboah wieder alle hände voll zu tun und
bei jedem patienten schwingt die angst
vor corona infektionen immer mit aber
dieser tag bringt auch hoffnung in ghana
sind die ersten impfstoffe eingetroffen
und dr yeboah wird als eine der ersten
ihre spritze bekommen
ich fühle mich so privilegiert dass ich
heute meine impfung gegen kuwait bekomme
600.000 dosen astrazeneca sind für
frontkämpfer in der pandemie wie dr
yeboah vorgesehen eine spende der kovacs
initiative die hilfen für die ärmsten
länder der welt organisiert mit der
ersten lieferung können rund ein prozent
der bevölkerung geimpft
ich denke es ist fair dass die
mitarbeiter im gesundheitsbereich zuerst
geimpft werden wenn man sich anschaut
wie sich die krankheit verbreitet dann
sind wir häufig die ersten die sich
anstecken
bevor wir sie dann weiter nach hause
tragen die große mehrheit wird noch
lange auf ihren impfschutz warten müssen
während reiche industrieländer hoffen
die herdenimmunität schon im sommer zu
erreichen könnte das in den ärmsten
staaten noch jahre dauern
mit dem risiko mühsam erzielte erfolge
wieder zunichte zu machen
ohne impfungen überall auf der welt
besteht die gefahr dass sich sogar
bereits geimpfte menschen wieder
anstecken
bei mutationen und neue varianten gerade
in den regionen entstehen können
in die nicht geimpft wurde
auch deshalb warnt die
weltgesundheitsorganisation unermüdlich
vor dem impf nationalismus der reicheren
länder die bereit sind immer höhere
preise für impfstoffe zu bezahlen
hier geht es nicht um wohltätigkeit das
ist eine frage der epidemiologie
solange wir die pandemie nicht überall
besiegen haben wir sie nirgends besiegt
die impfstoffe der großen pharmakonzerne
sind die begehrteste ware der welt und
jedes land will sie haben
deshalb hat die whu die kovacs
initiative mit ins leben gerufen die
soll mit geldern der reichsten nationen
impfstoffe kaufen und an die ärmsten
verteilen 600 millionen dosen für afrika
das ziel ist 20 prozent der bevölkerung
des jahresende zu impfen
kovacs setzt vor allem auf den
preiswerten astrazeneca impfstoff die
weltweite diskussion über nebenwirkungen
könnte vereinbarte deal ist jetzt
verzögern und zugang zu anderen
impfstoffen weiter erschweren weil die
reichen staaten den markt leer kaufen
von den 12,5 milliarden impfdosen die
dieses jahr produziert werden geht rund
die hälfte 64 milliarden dosen an muss
15 prozent der weltbevölkerung
deshalb sprechen wir von impfstoff
hamsterkäufen durch reiche länder
lucia war kann es sich nicht leisten zu
warten auch wenn sie als kellnerin
täglich hunderte kunden bedient die
alleinerziehende mutter lebt in kibera
dem größten slum in kenias hauptstadt
nairobi
sie muss geld verdienen ihre familie
ernähren und sie hat angst weil jeder
ihrer gäste die krankheit mit bringen
könnte
jeder sollte geimpft werden
vor allem leute die wie wir mit so
vielen menschen kontakt haben
ich wäre gern geimpft damit ich mich
nicht bei anderen anstecken kann und
damit sich die krankheit nicht an andere
weiter trage sowie lucie hat auch martin
murli keine chance kontakte zu vermeiden
als batu schaffner lutz er jeden tag die
herrscher der arbeitenden bevölkerung
mit dem kleinbus durch nach oben wie so
viele andere hofft er als kleines rad im
wuseligen wirtschaftsbetriebe irgendwie
durch die pandemie zu kommen sie
konzentrieren sich nur auf eine kleine
gruppe leute wie wir müssen auf arbeiten
wenn ich nicht zur arbeit komme verdiene
ich kein geld
und irgendwie muss ich ja das
notwendigste bezahlen weil die kovacs
initiative auch in kenia nur schleppend
in gang kommt sucht die regierung
händeringend nachschub und führt bereits
verhandlungen mit russland und china
ohne astrazeneca stünde der impfplan
vieler afrikanischer länder auf der
kippe
die whu steht unter wachsendem druck
angekündigte versprechen auch
einzuhalten
ich kann mir nicht vorstellen dass er
seine massive kursänderung gibt wie mit
den astra zeneca im stoffen umgegangen
wird die in indien und südkorea
produziert werden und bereits in rund
100 länder ausgeliefert werden
die kovacs initiative hat ehrlich gesagt
auch kaum eine wahl mit sie den astra
zeneca impfstoff aussetzen wäre das
gleichbedeutend mit dem ende des
programms
in simbabwe wollte sich die regierung
von anfang an nicht allein auf hilfen
aus dem westen verlassen und hat gleich
den chinesischen sinopharm impfstoff
gekauft
auch wenn der von der whu noch nicht
zugelassen ist und obwohl es zweifel
gibt dass er gegen die mutante aus dem
nachbarland südafrika schützt china und
auch russland nutzen in immer mehr
ländern afrikas nur zu bereitwillig die
gelegenheit das eigene image mit
impfstofflieferungen aufzupolieren
einige der länder aus dem reichsten club
der welt den sieben sind zunehmend
besorgt
sie fürchten dass russland und china
ihren einfluss durch impfstoffe ausbauen
weil sie die rolle einnehmen die kovacs
eigentlich haben sollte und sich jetzt
als retter der bevölkerung präsentieren
simbabwe wurde hart von der zweiten
welle getroffen und die menschen haben
angst dass es noch einmal so schlimm
werden könnte
in seiner klinik hat dr marisa viele
patienten verloren
freunde und familienangehörige sind
gestorben kovacs alleine reiche nicht
aus sagt er
solange die impfstoffe sicher sind ist
ihm auch hilfe aus china und russland
recht 20 prozent der bevölkerung zu
impfen bringt gar nichts
das ziel sind 70 prozent wenn wir zehn
prozent impfen und die gemeinschaft
nicht schützen können ist das als würden
wir gar nichts tun das ist nur eine
verschwendung von ressourcen im kampf
gegen korona muss die menschheit das
virus überall besiegen
afrika ist auf schnell verfügbare
impfstoffe angewiesen ohne astrazeneca
könnte die kovacs initiative scheitern
und solange immer neue mutationen
entstehen werden auch geimpfte
gesellschaften nicht in sicherheit seien